"According to last week's survey, most
voters were disappointed by legislators'
inability working together on key issues,
[or] no error. So, the part that feels
fishy to me is, right around here,
because we are talking about "legislators'
inability [to] work together". Let's read
the whole thing. "According to last week's
survey, most voters were disappointed by
legislators' inability [to] work together
on key issues". Right, what are they
complaining about? The "inability [to]
work together". They are not complaining
about, "inability working together". That
doesn't even actually make any grammatical
sense. I don't even know what, "inability
working together" even means. They're
trying to say, "inability to work together
on key issues". So, it is definitely part C,
right over here, where we have the error.